politique
bonsoir et bienvenue dans les deux
politiques votre rendez-vous politique
du dimanche soir sur Radio sensation en
association avec TV 78 épisode 242 ce
soir mon invité et Jean-Michel
fourgousse
nos politiques
Jean-Michel fourgouse bonsoir bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
merdéencourt depuis 1996 et président de
la communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines depuis 2017
vous avez été député aussi de la 11e
circonscription des Yvelines entre 1993
et 1997 et de 2002 à 2012 vous avez
toujours été membre de la droite c'est
votre famille politique vous êtes membre
des républicains alors votre famille
politique justement traverse une période
compliquée au niveau national 199
députés en 2012 101 en 2017 et puis 61
en 2022 plusieurs divisions sont
apparues encore récemment comment est-ce
que vous vous analysez la situation
est-ce que des
erreurs ont été commises au cours de ces
dernières années alors d'abord la vie
politique elle repose sur les élus
à tous les niveaux il y a 600 environ
élus en France
bon il y a les élus municipaux ou là LR
est en tête c'est le premier parti il y
a les élus de départementaux
idem c'est à nouveau les républicains
qui sont en tête
les élus régionaux
idem c'est elle est aussi qui est en
tête
et puis au Sénat je crois que c'est bon
mais où il semble que en plus la
tendance je pense ça doit rester bon
faut être toujours pas être prudent bon
comme
les élus que vous avez cités différents
collectivités
pour cela mais bon alors là vous me
parlez de l'Assemblée nationale
effectivement l'actualité le zoom des
journalistes c'est toujours 65 mais
toute façon tout le monde est en crise
je vous rappelle que vous n'avez plus de
majorité
c'est on voit l'ambiance qu'il y a
l'Assemblée nationale c'est très
difficile
de dire qu'il y aurait une majorité il y
a pas il y a pas quelqu'un qui a une
majorité claire donc absolue parce que
absolu c'est plus de 50% très difficile
de diriger bien sûr avec une minorité à
l'Assemblée donc voilà les élus c'est
au-dessus de la France ce n'est pas et
en plus ça semble national elle subit le
vent et on le voit
et vous pouvez très bien d'ici la fin
d'année avoir une dissolution ne
serait-ce que sur le sur le budget si
la majorité ne n'y a pas de majorité
pour éviter le budget là vous vous
rentrez dans des considérations assez
difficiles et vous êtes quasiment obligé
dissolution bon donc je dirais attendons
un peu plus de lisibilité
mais je souhaiterais pas être à la place
du président de la République
aujourd'hui ce que c'est elle est assez
c'est un parti sérieux ils ont nul n'est
parfait bon mais c'est quand même le
parti du général de Gaulle de Georges
Pompidou enfin c'est pas n'importe quoi
c'est pas des agitateurs d'émotions
d'image des séducteurs des
du théâtre permanent c'est c'est bon
Georges Pompidou enfin Jacques Chirac
Sarkozy enfin c'est quand même des gens
bon voilà c'est c'est des responsable
c'est des gens qui se battent sur la
valeur travail fondamentale sur sur
budgétaire vous avez vu le déséquilibre
budgétaire qui est aujourd'hui enfin
c'est du jamais vu j'ai comment va-t-on
rembourser 3000 milliards de net c'est
impossible aujourd'hui ou alors il faut
augmenter la croissance massivement mais
faut le dire là que il y a pas de il y a
pas de il y a plus de parler vrai
aujourd'hui c'est que de l'image c'est
c'est de la séduction permanente bon
voilà donc LR n'est pas dans la
séduction c'est un parti sérieux de gens
responsables qui sont inscrits dans la
vie économique souvent et vous savez il
y a pas de social sans économie si vous
n'est pas si vous avez si vous ne savez
pas produire la richesse que vous
contentez d'un discours c'est la
redistribution uniquement discours
redistributif voilà vous êtes dans vous
dites pas la vérité donc voilà donc
c'est quand même un parti du parler vrai
voilà qui donc là ce que je peux vous
dire Monsieur comment comment préparer
l'avenir maintenant de LR Othman Nasro
conseiller municipal de trappes et
vice-président de la Région
Île-de-France que vous connaissez bien a
été nommé Premier Secrétaire général
délégué du parti par Eric ceci le
président des LR alors comment rebondir
enrayer cette cette dynamique s'appuyait
sur les justement les collectivités
territoriales aujourd'hui et porter la
voix des territoires ça doit être le
chemin
choisi par LR alors si vous n'avez pas
de croissance
vous n'aurez pas on pourra pas payer vos
retraites on ne pourra pas payer les
services publics ne fonctionnaires donc
voilà
la croissance le secret de la croissance
c'est l'innovation
alors Saint-Quentin bien sûr la chance
d'être un territoire assez privilégié en
termes d'innovation on est un des gros
PIB par habitant avec bien sûr un nombre
de brevets qui sont déposés si toute la
France se ressemblait à Saint-Quentin
votre niveau de vie serait je sais pas 4
fois supérieur vous imaginez bon donc
c'est c'est quand même assez sexuel
alors
est un épiler de cette culture
d'innovation
jehc d'ailleurs très proche de la
présidente bien sûr de la région
première région d'Europe
donc c'est vrai que LRD il y a un
rajeunissement et un renouvellement avec
des gens avec des gens qui ont justement
une culture économique parce que demain
si vous voulez diriger le pays il suffit
pas d'avoir une culture littéraire moi
je suis docteur c'est bien mais
heureusement j'ai aussi une formation
scientifique bon et demain les réponses
à notre pays les solutions à notre pays
elles sont scientifiques elles sont
techniques elles sont numériques elles
sont économiques si vous n'avez aucun
des quatre si on pouvait demander à ces
gens-là de se mettre un peu à l'écart
momentané vous voyez de la gouvernance
de demain de notre pays pour le
redresser ce serait une bonne chose
c'est promis dès qu'on retrouve en
équilibre voilà mais on veut des gens
qui soient soit une formation soit une
expérience dans cette de ces quatre
facteurs c'est fondamental et si elle en
cours est une réussite 650 ici c'est
aussi parce que l'équipe qui dirige
en grande majorité cette double culture
on va passer maintenant
à la partie locale de cette émission et
parler de 50 ans en Yvelines
l'hebdopolitique
toujours avec Jean-Michel fourgouse
président LR de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et maire
d'Élancourt on parle beaucoup vous
l'avez dit de l'Assemblée nationale et
du gouvernement la politique c'est aussi
les communautés d'agglomération pourquoi
Jean-Michel fourgousse selon vous elles
sont primordiales dans la vie de nos
concitoyens que j'étais avec Gérard
Larcher il y a deux jours enfin ça fasse
tous les deux une heure et il me disait
que l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin
effectivement était une des
agglomérations économiquement les plus
puissantes de France ont été très
contents de conseils et ça mais en fait
on voit bien que l'innovation
aujourd'hui ne se fait plus dans l'état
l'État c'est c'est très paralysé c'est
très
il veille à rester dans la conformité
dans dans le conservatif alors que le
monde bouge
l'innovation c'est dans les territoires
aujourd'hui et on le voit au travers de
Saint-Quentin mais pas que dans
Saint-Quentin on voit bien que ce qui
sort ce qui bouge ce qui fait réussir le
bar c'est l'entreprise vous savez comme
on dit souvent en entreprise c'est la
solution l'État c'est le problème parce
que les détails il est complètement je
dirais paralysé par par la vitesse
d'évolution du monde et voilà mais bon
alors on doit travailler il faut quand
même qui est une réconciliation minimum
comme entre l'État et l'entreprise mais
il faut que les lois
s'adaptent à la réalité et non pas des
cabinets des fantasmes de jeunes
sciences je connais cette maison mais
qui sortent de de l'école donc qui n'ont
aucune expérience ça veut dire qu'ils
n'ont aucune compétence tout individu
qui n'a aucune expérience n'a aucune
compétence alors qu'il l'équerre voilà
mais mais comment peut-on on peut pas
faire des lois qui dépendent de de gens
qui idéalisent qui réalise le pouvoir
qui est c'est comme disent les paysans
la terre elle ne ment pas et en fait la
vérité les sur le terrain c'est pour ça
que les élus locaux ça a été une erreur
de couper le mandat des élus locaux et
des députés mais quelle erreur mon Dieu
vous avez des gens qui sont complètement
isolés qui que des lois mais qui
comprennent absolument pas l'application
et nous on est donc
le plus rapidement possible si on veut
sauver la France il faut absolument
remettre de la compétence de
l'expérience dans dans à l'Assemblée
nationale alors au Sénat c'est moins le
cas parce que c'est un peu moins
problématique que plus d'effets
d'expérience bon mais Assemblée
nationale c'est alors je sais pas s'il y
aura des prochaines élections mais en
tout cas je fais passer le message à nos
électeurs de grâce plutôt que de soit de
gauche ou droite qui nous mettent des
gens d'expérience qui qui comprennent
l'économie voilà qui comprennent
l'innovation laganisation du monde voilà
qui sortent pas avec des grandes idéaux
de l'ENA ou de Sciences Po de Grasse si
on pouvait faire évoluer cette satellite
qui va absolument diriger qui veut
absolument le pouvoir que l'on mette des
gens qui ont fait leurs preuves quand on
veut faire des lois on doit avoir fait
ses preuves donc quelque chose on ne
peut pas abandonner ça à des gens qui
qui ne vont pas sur le terrain nous
libère c'est pour ça qu'on était mais on
est je crois les élus les plus aimés du
français parce que parce qu'on leur dit
la vérité parce que ils comprennent on
leur dit ce qu'il voit puisque on voit
la même chose vous voyez donc on se
respecte et moi j'ai été ça fait la
cinquième fois que je suis l'humain oui
mais pourquoi parce que mes électeurs me
le disent mais je me prouve pour moi ils
me disent parce que vous vous en parler
vrai un peu direct une fois bon mais et
puis vous vous avez des résultats voilà
leur Sky la priorité en 2022 c'était
l'emploi c'est l'élan en tout cas que
que vous souhaitez donner à la
communauté d'agglomération vous avez
accueilli justement l'étape du Big tour
de BPI France récemment donc à la fin de
la l'année 2022 l'emploi ça sera encore
une priorité en 2023 pour pour Sky bah
vous savez on a 145
000 emplois sur Saint-Quentin et on a
000 habitants donc si vous enlevez les
enfants bon je vais pas vous dire vous
êtes quasiment un emploi un habitant
mais bon parce qu'il y a des gens de
l'extérieur qui travaillent il faut le
dire mais cela dit bien entendu le le
rapport est assez et bon c'est évident
alors maintenant c'est sur Saint-Quentin
c'est des secteurs très stratégiques
les secteurs de la défense secteur de la
cybersécurité
secteur du bâtiment et que Bouygues de
l'aéronautique pour une balance
commerciale c'est extraordinaire le
secteur bancaire aussi qui était assez
fort le le
même le secteur de la santé on a on a on
a quand même des secteurs d'excellence
et qui en fait attirent des compétences
de haute valeur ajoutée et donc on forme
on doit former encore plus et les
entreprises nous le demandent encore il
y a eu deux jours sur l'emploi vous le
savez au Vélodrome qui serait absolument
extraordinaire on nous demande de
d'aller encore plus loin plus vite sur
la formation des élites ils ont besoin
de compétences et là on a la chance
d'avoir bien sûr l'université
première université scientifique
mondiale en mathématiques qui
permettront cette transition numérique
or le numérique bien sûr est à
Saint-Quentin c'est pas le seul mais
bien sûr il est quand même très présent
puisque vous savez que demain 85 % des
emplois qui existeront n'existent pas
aujourd'hui et c'est le numérique qui
bien sûr joue un rôle très important la
transformation donc on prépare et on
anticipe nous on est vraiment dans
l'innovation on prépare ses futurs
métiers on prépare ses formations des
nouvelles méthodes pour former les gens
plus vite un hôpital du futur pour pour
répondre plus aux besoins de nos
citoyens concitoyens et c'est un drame
cette histoire sur la santé bon vous
avez vu même pour le le covid il a fallu
improviser alors bon ça s'est bien passé
à Saint-Quentin parce que si on est de
belles entreprises qui nous aident faut
pas vous l'aurez si si on est j'ai vu
qu'on a eu le premier prix sur 1800
centre de vaccination mais forcément
Saint-Quentin un gros avantage
dans le covid et puis je vous rappelle
qu'on a des des partenaires et moi aussi
je faut rendre à César ce qui appartient
à César mais on félicite c'est bien mais
j'ai pas tout seul d'abord il y a une
bonne équipe de mer qui pilote et avec
un certain climat de confiance bon je
lui bloque tant les pas d'accord sur un
ou deux sujets mais le moment ça
fonctionne avec le département aussi qui
est quand même un département puissant
avec la région avec Paris Seclin donc on
a cette culture d'innovation et un
minimum de moyens je vous dis si c'était
la France ce serait mais en même temps
bien entendu il y a une concentration
d'entreprises en plus on met moins de 30
minutes si vous partez de Paris le matin
du périphérique près de la Porte de
Saint-Cloud vous arrivez à au Vélodrome
en moins de 30 minutes 100 feux rouges
100 euros le matin dans ce sens là parce
que bon bien sûr donc voilà tout ça sont
des atouts puis on a les JO bon vous le
savez qui vont qui aussi vont augmenter
l'attractivité encore de Saint-Quentin
donc voilà je vais pas vous dire qu'on
est malheureux même si on a des chutes
de recettes de la part de l'État qui
sont qui sont insupportables je voudrais
vous parler maintenant Jean-Michel
fourgouse de la sécurité c'est une année
importante pour 50 ans en Yvelines
puisque les travaux du nouveau
commissariat d'agglomération vont
débuter donc cette année en quoi ce
nouvel outil permettra-t-il donc de
d'améliorer la sécurité des habitants de
l'agglomération d'abord il va mieux
coordonner
la formation la réactivité
bien sûr et donc la rapidité de la
décision bien sûr l'intervention ou
d'accompagnement
entre les trois commissariats de
Guyancourt de trappes et d'Élancourt
deuxièmement bien sûr
sur l'accompagnement la réception
l'accueil des victimes bien entendu une
autre façon beaucoup plus humaine et
bien sûr de de de les accompagner
je veux dire qu'un processus de décision
même au niveau départemental et
on transmet des images beaucoup plus
vite les décisions sont de meilleure
qualité donc c'est l'objectif c'est
c'est bien entendu améliorer la sécurité
de nos administrer également
utiliser toutes les dernières
technologies qui sortent et qui concerne
bien sûr la sécurité
ou c'est le numérique ça impacte tout
c'est un pas que la santé bien sûr vous
savez
vous avez vu cette histoire sur le le
l'antivirus le vaccin contre le cancer
mais faut voir tous les laboratoires
maintenant ils échangent beaucoup plus
vite depuis le la recherche du covid
avec l'ARN messager bon le numérique est
un impact sur la santé et vous aurez
peut-être un virus à l'antivirus avec ça
sur le contre le cancer dans les
peut-être dans les trois ans on imagine
si c'est vrai
c'est énorme donc le monde se transforme
la façon de travailler la façon
d'apprendre la façon de voyager et on
nous on est partout là dessus dans cette
culture numérique on est dans
l'innovation à suivre vraiment à
accompagner et dont la sécurité pourrait
répondre à la question oui on va on va
on a le commissariat du futur qui a été
attribué à 50 ans alors c'est pareil il
faut rendre à 16h tu atteint ce qui nous
a aidé pour la voir c'est quand même un
régime on va se le dire
sur la transition écologique maintenant
50 ans en Yvelines doit aussi donc
poursuivre cette transition vous avez
bâti un plan r selon les études donc 48
000 personnes meurent chaque année à
cause de la pollution de de l'air la
pollution atmosphérique
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ne fait pas
partie de la ZFE du donc mise en place
autour de Paris comment vous vous
comptez faire pour baisser justement les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
alors premièrement l'ivo est douce pour
diminuer un peu l'activité automobile on
est je vous rappelle on a 450 km de
pistes assez rare dans une agglomération
je crois qu'on est une des rares et on
va aller jusqu'à 600 km donc pour 2030
alors certes on a quatre sites
olympiques dont 3 vélos donc de toute
façon on n'a pas le choix parce que nos
ennemis
trois sites de vélo là il faut
accélérer donc on accélère
vous allez par exemple avoir la
coordination entre les quatre sites
olympiques
par recyclable c'est quand même assez
extraordinaire plus la gare vous
imaginez de la gare vous allez pouvoir
faire le tour même le dimanche avec vos
enfants vous pourrez aller vous balader
sur les pistes et faire tout le grand
tour aller sur le golf revenir sur la
colline des langues en plus vous aurez
des pistes assez extraordinaire comme
vous l'avez compris après sur l'île de
loisirs enfin on est en train de bien
sûr de construire un espèce de sport
loisir une ambiance pour loisirs famille
quand même qui est extraordinaire et
puis c'est la qualité de l'air et puis
la communauté en cours si vous voulez
bien respirer vous avez gagné on reste
très bien on va aussi mais vous pouvez
envoyer de la colline bon on a toute des
instrumentalisations scientifiques on a
financé un satellite vous le savez un
anneau satellite qui est qui est parti
il y a quelques jours et qui étudie bien
sûr les variables de de un peu de de
cette de ces changements de climat donc
on met bon on met on met beaucoup de
gens on travaille sur les capteurs d'air
actuellement sur les la qualité de l'air
et pour aller avoir une forme de capteur
d'air on a on va bientôt un zeppelin
aussi qui va aussi faire des études de
climat pour toujours essayer de faire
avancer la notion de de d'outillage pour
pour capter
la captation de CO2 en fait bon donc
voilà beaucoup de choses alors après je
peux vous donner une bonne question sur
le sur le problème de l'eau ensuite
alors si je vous termine en tout cas
voilà il y a je vous rappelle qu'elle
soit 60% à 50 ans peu de gens de ça
visiblement
l'espace naturel donc bon on n'a pas les
on n'est pas marqué l'espace comment à
Paris ou banlie
urbanisé c'est on est beaucoup moins
organisé bien sûr ce qui fait qu'il y a
une plus grande qualité de vie et donc
une plus grande qualité de l'air mais on
va chercher encore à améliorer ça on
s'en fait on travaille des entreprises
d'ailleurs de Saint-Quentin là-dessus
donc Jean-Claude de Caunes enfin on a on
est plus entreprises plusieurs
laboratoire Paris Saclay aussi qui est
quand même bourré de laboratoire et de
chercheurs très pointu là-dessus donc ça
fait partie bien sûr de notre de notre
deal toujours sur l'écologie un mot sur
les trottinettes électriques vous donc
vous avez vu j'imagine vous avez suivi
l'affaire parisienne avec ce référendum
donc les Parisiens abandonnent les
trottinettes électriques en
libre-service ici à Saint-Quentin ça
marche et vous en êtes plus que
satisfait le développement va se
poursuivre dans les années à venir alors
d'abord moi je vous ferai une remarque
c'est un référendum mais c'est bon on
fait rêver les Français en disant
démocratie participative référendum
c'est très bien oui c'est parfait mais
il faut pas que qu'on oublie qu'il y a
il y a quand même une démocratie
représentative sont sur les élus faut
pas nier cela les aiguilles sont là pour
prendre des décisions ils connaissent
les dossiers ils reçoivent les leurs
administrés ils ont une information
quand même plus exhaustive là il y a 6%
de participation seulement à ce
référendum je vous avoue que c'est un
problème c'est un problème démocratique
si on laisse prendre des décisions comme
ça faisant penser que c'est une forme de
démocratie attention bon alors bien sûr
ce sont les plus âgés d'entre nous ce
que je comprends ils utilisent pas être
dînettes c'est les agaces à Paris en
plus des jeunes qui se font si je
comprends la réaction de nos seniors
mais bon vous savez il en faut pour tout
le monde alors pourquoi nous on le garde
parce que d'abord on n'a pas les mêmes
problèmes
bien sûr qu'à Paris on n'a pas la même
concentration bien sûr
de bus vous les voyez dans dans ce cas
dans ce filet dans ce bus de taxi il y a
les motos il y a les vélos il y a les
trottinettes mais forcément il y a les
accidents on n'a pas la même chose du
tout on n'a pas tout le même
fonctionnement deuxièmement on n'a pas
des trottinettes qui qui s'étales sur
les trottoirs on doit rendre sinon on
garde votre carte on continue à débiter
donc les gens remettent bien les
trottinettes bien sûr aux endroits de
base on n'a pas tous les moyens on a des
clignotants on a bien sûr un casque mais
donc on essaie de le faire respecter un
maximum on a
on a comment dirais enfin on a pas mal
de choses
on a aussi une immatriculation ça veut
dire que si un type fait le zouave on
l'arrête et il a une amende c'est pas le
cas sur sur d'autres sur tous les autres
trottinettes de marque on a qu'une seule
marque et c'est mieux pour travailler
avec un partenaire si vous avez cinq
partenaires mais vous gérez pas de la
même façon là vous voyez on passe des
engagements on les contrôle on les
change si un problème c'est pour ça que
ça fonctionne en tout cas il y a en
termes d'accident je vous dis et que
quelques accidents il y a encore léger
donc on a pas on n'a pas la gravité des
éléments qu'on a vu sur Paris mais je
vous dis fort reconnaître que bon madame
midelgo bien sûr elle est contrainte que
vous êtes sur Paris je sais pas si la
trottinette était totalement adaptée
pour Paris ou là c'est peut-être la
question qu'il faut se poser pour finir
cette émission Jean-Michel fourgon
j'aimerais parler de la création du
premier festival de musique électronique
à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines c'est que ça
se passera sur l'île de loisirs c'est
l'agglomération qui lance donc ce
festival musical ça se passera le 7 et
le 8 juillet prochain pourquoi ce
souhait de l'agglomération de créer cet
événement Jean-Michel fogos
et bien parce que on a nos jeunes alors
les trottinettes sont contents il y a
pas de problème c'est mais bien sûr
qu'il y a des services qui sont très
ciblés d'un éclates faut pas se le
cacher bon donc il faut il demande plus
d'animation bon ben écoutez on a eu par
le samedi soir un festival techno à
donc au lieu de Drôme parce que c'était
compliqué dans une autre région alors
bon au dernier moment ils ont dit allez
on prend le vélo de route mais en plus
aujourd'hui de Saint-Quentin une image
assez forte donc le vélodrome peut
devenir aussi
extraordinaire il y a le salon des
étudiants il y a c'est extraordinaire
bon hier c'était le salon de l'emploi
c'était le salon de l'innovation et ça
n'arrête pas mais très bien c'est ça
donne une image extraordinaire bon donc
il y a eu 3000 jeunes déjà sur un
festival techno samedi soir et il y a
donc la musique techno qui bien sûr
plait une certaine catégorie si la
population donc vous voyez on est là
pour aussi répondre à bien sûr à tout le
monde et en fait c'est un grand festival
rayonnement international d'ailleurs qui
aura lieu le
que je dis pas de me baisser le 7 juin
celle-ci c'est 7 juin je crois juillet
on attend 10 000 personnes environ voilà
par exemple on a on a un autre plus
petit festival c'est les années 80
concert des années 80 qu'elle lui a
Élancourt le samedi 24 juin
c'est les années 80 à 2001 et à Guy
Bonifacio bon mais c'est pour les moins
jeunes voyons on essaye de de de faire
pour tout le monde celui qui a lieu
samedi soir c'est encore une autre
catégorie même en même en musique techno
que celle que la grosse qui a lieu donc
le 6 et 7 juin c'est un lieu important
pour l'agglomération bah écoutez c'est
la plus grosse île de loisirs
d'Île-de-France 600 hectares il y a 150
hectares de plan d'eau qui est très joli
d'ailleurs
alors on a on est en plus en ce moment
plusieurs projets qu'on étudie avec la
région
non il se dit c'est c'est extraordinaire
c'est quand même un coin assez
extraordinaire si vous voulez envie de
vous changer j'ai pas besoin de prendre
un avion
pour aller je sais pas dans le Bordelais
ou sur la Côte d'Azur bon vous pouvez
aller vous promener sur l'île loisirs on
va faire le tour ou faire un jogging
autant vous allez voir c'est quand même
assez extraordinaire
donc on est on est quand même gâté je
vous dis à Saint-Quentin aussi bien en
termes d'emplois on l'a dit emploi de
qualité en plus en termes de sécurité
avec des projets en termes de santé avec
les l'hôpital du futur en termes
d'éducation je vous rappelle que
Saint-Quentin a été invité à
l'Exposition universelle pour
représenter la France pour montrer
l'innovation en pédagogie plus il y aura
bientôt aussi les Jeux Olympiques merci
beaucoup Jean-Michel fourgon d'avoir été
avec nous je rappelle donc que vous êtes
le président de la communauté
d'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines et le maire d'Élancourt nous on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de l'hebd politique sur
Radio sensation et sur TV 78 très bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]